e
e e
good
morning being 10:00 we'll call the
fiscal committee meeting to order for
April 19th
2024 and the first item is item one
acceptance of the minutes move to
approve Senator gray moves to approve
Senator rosenell seconds is there any
additions or Corrections seeing none all
in favor say I
I the minutes are appr any
opposed the minutes are
approved next tab is old
business recognize Senator
burdel I would like to move um the item
that off the
table all right a motion and a second to
take item FIS has 24088 off the table
further discussion seeing none all in
favor say I I oppose no oppose no all
right that item is off the table and
open for discussion I recognize Senator
bdel
um I move I don't I'm sorry I don't have
the item in front of me I move the
item motion to move the item is there a
second second second by Senator G
further discussion seeing none all in
favor say I I oppose
no item is off the
table that's approved no I mean that
item is approved it's off the table and
approved moving on to the consent
calendar which goes from tabs 3 through
8 uh under tab three item 24-1 143 has
been withdrawn so that will not be
included the following items have been
removed by the
house 24 under tab three
2413 that that's item that's under tab
three under
tab five
24144 and under tab
six
24136 are there any other items to be
removed from the consent
calendar seeing none I'll entertain a
motion to accept the remainder move
second all right motion by Senator
Bradley seconded by Senator gray to
approve the rest of the consent calendar
all in favor say I I oppose
no those items are approved and we move
to the first item remove move from
consent 24-1
132 from the prescription drug
affordability
board representative good
morning good morning
chair Senator Edwards is recognized uh
thank you Mr
chair I um I I don't this is okay this
is the first time the fiscal committee
has seen a pdab request and so I just
want to make sure that the fiscal
committee and and and the public know
something about the PAB process um on
the on the signature part of
this it's it seems appropriate according
to a conversation with Mr Kain that Mr
William Williamson sign these directly
and that they come directly to us uh as
a as a matter of policy given that
you're administratively attached to the
Department of Health and Human Services
I I I I wonder allowed for you to
consider whether it would be appropriate
to do a a cc over to like Mr White just
for some situational Awareness on these
um
transfers good morning member of the
committee chairman wer um the department
of Min the Department of Health and
Human Services worked closely um with
with representative merch and and Mr
Williamson on this request we we
provided technical support to help move
this through the process so we were very
aware of this I just want to make that
very clear okay that's great that's what
I'm was hoping for there's just no
indication in here that it's been
coordinated with the with the
department and and I was thinking maybe
a cc at the bottom or something might do
that but I I don't want to get into the
Weeds on that um the the next thing uh I
would ask uh represent a merchant is uh
did this action this trans these
transfer funds and the setting up of the
new accounts did that uh get pdab Board
review and
approval it was not raised specifically
um the issue is raised with some of the
board members by not taking per se a
vote by the board Bo um it felt it was
more housekeeping it was more of a
technical issue than it was a policy
issue okay so I'm I'm not going to get
on the weed in the Weeds on that but I I
it would be good to know if there's a a
formal methodology to have the board
approve these before uh they get
released by U Mr Hut Williamson I would
say as we get down the road and we go
through the process of standing up this
Sport and going through a learning curve
that is something we should probably be
Tal Ru making to be clear what the
process is right now it's not dealt with
in the rules um we're basically going at
this um as much as we possibly can based
upon what we have available to us okay
and then U there's a dollar here on the
table for agency income um is what what
is the status of setting up the account
for these uh donations or uh
contributions to be uh made to the board
that was brought up at the last board
meeting um represent Edwards um at this
point in time we has to go through Ru
making in order to have a process in
place to accept donations so that is
something the board will be tackling
probably Mr Williamson himself along
with support staff from the Department
Health Human Services okay and and then
uh for disclosure I should uh let people
know I'm a member of the pdap board so
but right now I'm asking this from a
fiscal committee perspective um and I
would say that these new line account
lines uh for things like travel um they
all make sense they pass the common
sense test given the level of maturity
of the pdab board and process I I would
just suggest if uh if we're going to
have a
document uh signed by somebody who is
going to uh be a beneficiary of the
transfer of funds that that's more
important for those kinds of actions to
be uh sent and approved by the board so
that we avoid an appearance of conflict
it's well I hear you I think it's
something we need to again address in
the rules when we go through the process
um it's a well taken by myself I think
also members of the board but at this
point in time we need to go through Ru
making process in order to have that
process in place okay I I accept all of
that and with with that Mr chair if
there's no other discussion I would move
to
approve motion by representative Edwards
seconded by Senator rosenal to approve
the item is there any further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I I oppose
no report is
adopted moving on to tab five and FIS
24133 again Health and Human Services
Department of Public Health division of
Public Health
good
morning introduce
yourself sure my name is Ian watt I'm
the interim director for the director
for the division of Public Health
Services thank you we recognize Mr White
is fairly
constant person before US Representative
Edwards is recognized for a question uh
thank you Mr chair and I don't know how
it's happened but since we've changed
room I've lost my copy of
133 and so I'm not sure what my
questions were could could I borrow
somebody's 133
yes thank you
um oh I know what this was uh so my my
my my I think it's great that we're
going to have good visual information to
uh report out on our health status I
think that's great um I'm I'm I I'm
curious if we've done any mockups
already of what kind of information
might be available for for very specific
example what what my my pet passion is
these days is I would like to to see and
maybe include on the future dashboards
that's a different discussion uh the
information related to uh the number of
uh childhood covid shots that we've
given out uh I I I I think think that
um we're putting our kids at risk having
them take the covid shot uh even though
um CDC says it's okay and and but I do
want information on that well is that
could you could you provide us a copy of
a mockup of what kind of information
will be available using that specific
example so I I know what to expect when
the work is done sure so so this item
thank you for the question so this item
will allow us to hire uh via contract to
developers to assist us in developing
dashboards using our is the immunization
information system data when we bring
those two people on board they'll
actually be the experts in helping us
look at the data that we have and
analyze how we can best uh what is in
there what needs to be cleaned up and
and how we'll best be able to present
that as well as developing some mock-ups
and seeing you know what will be most uh
meaningful to us as an organization and
to the public to see uh it will not just
be uh covid Centric do have other uh
immunization information in there so the
the potential ways that we can cut this
data would be by age by geography by
vaccination and it would allow people to
see you know different um different ways
to look at our vaccine coverage in the
state followup question uh thank you Mr
chair I appreciate the answer I I I'm
I'm just expecting that some level of
understanding of what we want as a
deliverable needs to be known before we
issue an RFP and so I I would like to on
that particular effort I'd like to be
kept in the loop if possible I I know
I'm not in the executive branch but I
I'm I'm pretty curious about it all yeah
we will certainly be looking at the data
we have you know part of it and part of
our what our um our onboarded
contractors will do is look at the data
we have and the data quality to see what
data will be meaningful um the is as you
all know is an opin Resource as of July
20 or July 1st of 2023 it became opt-in
um which is to say the data that we have
is impacted by how many people opt in so
certainly the the relevance the
information and what we publish we want
to be relevant so we'll have to look at
what we have um but certainly we'll take
that into consideration as we we
developed our
dashboards all right no further followup
I I don't think that answered my
question but I appreciate your
response further questions from
committee representative
earth oh thank you than you take my
question so this is kind of a general
question you folks are probably not
exactly the right ones to ask but since
it's related to vaccines and data I'm
curious as whether the state of New
Hampshire considers looking at vaccine
related studies that perhaps the CDC um
does not consider worth worthy of
looking
at thank you for the question so we do a
thorough survey of of all scientific
data available um we have technical uh
evaluators we have our state
epidemiologist Ben Chan who I know you
all know so we we look at a full survey
of data not just data provided by the
CDC um and evaluate it based on you know
our own scientific capabilities and and
Analysis follow so it didn't mean
specifically Studies by the
CDC but studies that the CDC won't even
look at does the State of New Hampshire
look at variety of studies for instance
vaccines and autism as an example so I I
appreciate the question I apologize for
for not being clear so we will look at
studies Beyond just what is provided or
or available via the CDC um I can't
speak to what studies uh specifically
that they look at versus what we look at
but we do an expansive survey that's
very much independent of the cdc's
evaluation of of Technical and public
information fur the questions from
committee members how does the committee
wish to proceed on the item move the
item all right move to adopt the item
24133 second by Senator Rosenwald
further discussion seeing none you ready
for the question all in favor adopting
the report say I I opposed no the item
is adopted moving on to item num still
under Tab four item 24-1
144 can tab five thank You tab five item
241 144 maybe that was my problem I was
on the wrong tab
representa Edwards when you're
ready thank thank you Mr chair um M Mr
White I'm I'm just uh trying to
understand the the table here and and
what we're doing with the movement of
money um and so so I was trained debit
on the left credit on the right and what
we're what it seems like we're doing by
the write up my assumption is that uh as
we received Medicaid money we've um
taken a portion of it and set it aside
to serve as a uh a potential incentive
for performance or a punishment for poor
performance so we had it seemed like we
had the money in the system and we
administratively moved it to a
contingency fund and now we're trying to
move it from the contingency fund into a
line item where we can spend it with our
contractor
and and if that is a correct
interpretation then I would think that
the uh the bottom line here on total
expense would be zero because the money
would have already been
available and we're just moving line
items as opposed to the way it looks to
me which is like this is new additional
money so could you could you educate me
because I I know I don't understand this
well sure um so
I I I just want to start with this is a
unique request to the best of my
knowledge we've never had a request like
this before because this was a new
provision in the in the MCO contract
several years back um as part of that
contract a certain Actuarial sound uh
dollar amount was withheld each year and
those funds will be redistributed based
on certain performance metrics that
Henry can certainly speak to at Great
length um what we're seeking to do here
is to accept what would now be
considered the other funds and what we
would later do is write down um the the
equivalent amount of of General funds
from this account through through the
Bureau of accounts at D um the key here
is that we're accepting these other
funds into our budget so that we can
make payment um in accordance with the
the contractual and actu Actuarial
requirements of the agreement
I follow up so I I'll go offline with
you to try to understand that better I
I'm I'm still left thinking that we had
to administratively reserve the money at
some point and now we're just doing a a
a line item transfer but but I I'll
figure it out eventually if you're
patient with me of course and and that
other money would show up in the
statement of Appropriations but we
wouldn't have any Authority to actually
spend that other Revenue that that's why
we're putting this request here today
before the fiscal committee and again
this is the first time a request like
this has ever been done before just
because this was unique to the program
uh back in 2020 stting 20 2020
yes so I'm not concerned about what
we're doing I'm just I just want to make
sure that the documentation says what we
want the documentation to say and I can
interpret it and the public can
interpret it I I I take no issue with
what you you've done and and okay if
there if Mr chair I'd be ready to move
the uh item I want to see if Mr Litman
has something to
add I guess um I won't add to what he
said in terms of the accounting aspect
but in terms of the programmatic aspect
is that the the Actuarial rate that is
approved by governor and
Council that um 2% is
um uh put a side if you will for um the
mcos to earn um back if you will okay
it's it's not new money it's to earn
back what was in the rate and what we do
is create some competition within that
among the plans um so one plan can earn
part of another pl's 2% if they perform
better on the metrics um and so what
we're trying to do is use this as a
lever to lift up performance and create
some competition within the program and
meeting the
metrics last second representative
Edwards moves to adopt item 24144
Senator gray seconds further discussion
seeing none you ready for the question
all in favor say I
I oppose no the item is
adopted next item under tab
six 241
36 good
morning represent Edwards has recognized
for a question uh this wasn't mine I I'm
done for the morning s that's
representative
Earth thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my questions so my first question
is uh this makes reference to the
planning year end since the first this
is like the third and the series of
fiscal notes and the first one came out
about a year ago has the planning year
ended so with um
the so yes and no it's been extended so
we've had a planning year um but the
with this request and um Coming forth we
are asking that you approve us um
accepting the funds beyond the planning
air because we accepted them to a point
certain and we got an extension a no
cost extension in effect um from the
federal government um to continue the
project um because there are funds
remaining okay so I don't know if the
next question is particularly relevant
at this time but hopefully it will
become relevant at some point in the
future this makes reference to
basically a metrics you know let me
quote required quality measures a plan
for quality improvement and tracking of
other program requirements being made
well my question is will those could
those be made available now that the
first year has already been passed or
will they be made available in the
future at such point
is uh so um I apologize I never
introduced myself so I'm ctia Fox I'm
the director of the division for
Behavioral Health I just dove right in
um so uh those are great questions about
the timing and what's a planning year
and if the federal government extends
the planning period um when should we
expect what and and how that all
operates right now we continue to be in
that planning process in developing the
certified community behavioral health
clinics and a lot of the quality metrics
that you're referencing are once they're
up and running and that they'll have to
adhere to certain standards that we're
going to measure them on um so yes it's
a future question but it's it's a really
relevant question now about those
standards that are going to be uh
required and that they're in the process
of planning to be able to
meet senator rosemal for a
question thank you I'm just um curious
when the department plans to update
it's Community Mental Health Center
portion of the
dashboard which you told us like a year
or two ago that it was not accurate you
were working on it do you have an
estimate so um I will commit for it to
be updated um within the next 3 months
um it continues to be a work in progress
the Community Mental Health Centers had
real concerns and I believe they Express
them to you via letter at a point in
time saying they didn't believe that the
data was accurate um and so they have
been working uh very closely with our
data analytics um and their uh data
person and um I keep checking in and
saying you know when is this information
going to be updated what we did discover
is that there was a methodology that
they were using versus what we were
using and they thought that we were uh
wildly out of wax so to speak um and
however after further analysis and the
work that they've done together which
were much more close um than uh aart and
so therefore um the numbers that you do
see are accurate numbers because they
are from Financial claims not Medicaid
claims but they're out of our um Bureau
of mental health services so what you're
seeing is really important to focus on
the trends um which don't vary wildly um
from month to month but they aren't as
inaccurate as um we may have thought
previously however we do want to make
sure that the information is agreed upon
with the centers that we're presenting
to you and again within the next 3
months we should be able to reflect that
in the
dashboard further questions
all right Senator rosenal moves to
accept 24- 136 representative Earth
seconds is there any further discussion
seeing none all in favor say I I oppose
no and that item is adopted we'll move
on now to tab nine the regular
calendar and the first item is
24125 New Hampshire fishing game I see
the director here is here
this is consultants for the Brin
Hatchery are there any
questions Senate agree um in the last
budget not directly related to this uh
we were looking about uh snowmobile
registrations and I since I have you
here and in public for I certainly want
to take the opportunity to ask how that
programming is
coming thank you Senator uh my name is
Scott Mason executive director of um New
Hampshire fishing
game um we are currently on track for
the amendment to our
contract um my uh business office
manager is currently waiting for the
signed documentation to come back from
pay from pay it is the the company we've
been working with got bought out by pay
it and that is now the new name of the
company that we're doing business with
so we are anticipating that it that we
should have it in place by July first
the
contract that's uh good news and uh I
still get queries on that so I will
continue to query the department on that
myself so understood sir but we'll be
ready for the next snowfall
hopefully there's no other comments I'll
move the item if we have another no I'm
just teasing
it was a little sparse this year motion
by Senator gray second by Senator bsel
to adopt item 24125 is there any further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no that item is
adopted moving on to Tab
10 item
24118 Department of
Corrections any questions on this item
just positive motion I'll move the
item all right motion
by Senator Bradley second by Senator
bird s to adopt 24118 is there any
further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppos no the item is
adopted moving on to the next item on
Tab
11 request from the
LBA or
hiring move to approve Senator Senator
gray moves to approve the item Senator
rosenal seconds is there any further
discussion seeing none you ready for the
question all in favor say I I oppose no
the item is
adopted the rest of the items are
informational items anyone wish to have
excuse me representative just a one late
item oh late thank you very much
2448 thank you the late item is
24148 from the Department of
Transportation move the item Senator
Bradley moves to accept the item Senator
rosenal seconds is there any further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is
adopted all right now we can look at
informational items and see if anybody
has any questions
if there are no questions on the
informational items we'll be ready to
move to the audit
division all
right we'll get out our Audits and be
ready for that
report Mr chair you can make the motion
to accept release before or after the
presentation I'll link that up to the
committee all right all
right representative F would you read
the motion uh move to accept place on
file and release to the public in the
usual manner Senator gray
seconds all in favor say I I those no
item is adopted
and welcome Miss Young good morning Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the record I'm Christine Young
director of audits for the LBA
we're here to present the report on the
annual single audit of the state's
Federal
expenditures as you know our office
contracts with KPMG to conduct the
annual audit of the state's federal
assistance
programs joining us from KPMG is the
partner Marie
Zimmerman and also the preparer of the
single audit report from the Department
of administrative Services Charlie
Arling housee uh commissioner of
Das and uh with that I'll turn it over
to Marie for the presentation of the
report thank you and good morning
chairman and board I am re merman I am
returning as your lead external audit
partner and you get the yep thank you
and this morning I will be presenting
the results of our June 30th 2023
Federal single audit this is a
compliance audit in accordance with the
uniform guidance over the state's
Federal funding for the year ended 2023
the total federal expenditures reported
on the summary of expenditures in a
federal Awards or commonly known as the
ca was $3.6
billion this is relatively consistent
with previous years as the co portion of
expenditures has remained relatively
consistent with previous
years the seifa in section e of your
binder a book of the bound report begins
on page
E1 it reports all the programs listed by
aln number of the total expenditures
incurred during the year as well as the
amounts of the federal funds that have
been passed through of the state in this
past year 790 million funds were passed
through the state relatively consistent
with the previous year the ca is
prepared by the state by Das and as a
part of our audit we review the CA and
Pro form a variety of procedures to
ensure the completeness and accuracy of
the ca as it relates to the financial
statement opinions the financial
statement I had previously presented to
you and as a clean opinion in our
previous meeting as a part of this audit
on in section D of the book of the
report on page D3 I am glad to present
that the sea was in all material
respects in relation to the B basic
financial statement appro fairly
presented and we provided a clean
opinion as outlined by the uniform
guidance requirements we are not
required to audit every single program
of on the ca instead we're required to
focus our audits on certain larger
dollar programs that are defined as type
A as well as higher risk type B programs
Pro the uniform guidance this year based
upon your total fendra fundings of 3.6
billion that threshold of determining
which ones would be considered a type A
was
$10.7
Million which is noted in the summary of
our audit results beginning on page
F1 the uniform guidance requires us to
perform risk assessments over the type A
programs and once we have performed
those assessments and determined which
ones are major programs we then perform
it over the type B programs to determine
which programs we will be auditing this
p last year we audited 19 programs of
those 19 they totaled
2.99 550 billion or approximately $3
billion so of the total $3.6 billion
that were federal funds received by the
state we've audited three billion of
those the largest being Medicaid at 1.7
billion beginning on page F1 is our
summary of our audit results s which
lists the 19 major programs that we
audited in total there was 26 type A
programs but we deemed 16 of them to be
higher risk therefore we then selected
three type B programs which redeemed
higher risk the federal government has
deemed some of those programs to be
higher risk and as such we audit them
such as the disability cluster the three
type B programs that we audited last
year year are the block grant for
prevention and treatment of subsid abuse
the disability insurance and Si SSI
cluster as well as the supportive
effective instruct instruction state
grants of the 19 programs that we
audited last year 11 of those were re
were audited in June in the year ended
2022 they were repeat re audited in the
current year because they were deemed to
have be higher risk or deemed by the
federal government to be higher R such
as example as Medicaid Title One Snap
TANF and La
Heep we have really good news today to
report that over our procedures re
performed we identified 23 reportable
findings that is down from the previous
year where we had identified 32
findings those findings are outlined in
section D of the report of the 23
findings 20 of them were deemed to be
material weakness or breakdown of inter
controls over the specific compliance
areas that were being audited and three
were deemed to be significant
deficiencies 19 of the 23 were deemed to
have material
non-compliance seven of those
compliances related to reporting five
related to subrecipient modering two
related to period of performance and two
related to special test none I want to
point out none related to allowability
or eligibility compliance areas which is
a testament to your internal control
structure nine of these 19 material
non-compliances were within three
programs those programs are like Heap um
ELC and disaster
grants of the 23 reported findings 11
were repeat from the previous year of
which four were in Li Heep
program of the 23 we had two that had
question cost in both instances the
question cost related to the period of
performance compliance areas that was
were in the program education cluster
and the child support enforcement
Grant based on the findings of our audit
and procedures performed we're required
to provide an opinion related to each
compliance area of each major program
audited and based on the internal
control compliance findings identified
we they're identified in the summary of
our audit results we provided a
qualified opinion on 13 of the 19
programs
audited of the 13 program findings were
considered to be material instances of
non-compliance as Rel and material
weakness of internal controls as relates
to those specific compliance
areas we had an unmodified or clean
opinion over the remaining six programs
that we audited and I'm happy to report
that one of them is your Medicaid
Program your your SNAP program your
Highway planning and construction
program tanif clean water State
revolving fund and your emergency rental
program all received a modified or clean
opinions the findings themselves can be
identified or located on page F4 the
first finding I previously reported to
you relates to the financial statement
audit relating to the unemployment trust
fund um it's a significant deficiency
around reconciliation of accounts then
starting on find2 is the findings
relating to the compliance of the
federal stle
audit for each finding management is
required to provide a response to the
finding and a corrective action plan
this year those corrective action plans
are on agency letterhead in section8 of
the report as outlined in our opinion
the state is responsible for preparing
the corrective action plans and the
state it response are not subject to our
audit as a result we do not express an
opinion over the corrective action plans
we had no disagreements with management
and we had no changes in our audit
approach throughout the audit I'd like
to thank management Das LBA but also
those that are in the program that are
administrating the program that's so
important to the constituents of the
state for all their time and effort and
providing us with the detail for us to
be able to report to you today our
overall clean opin opinion does anyone
have any questions or do do I turn it
over to you I'll just I'll just say
something real quick usually you would
see Dana call here so just pretend I'm
her um uh Charlie Arling house I'm the
commissioner of the agency and uh we
have a very strong team that works on
this notably Dana and her team but um
Steve J vanelli and I had to mention him
because of his last name and I thought
Senator dallis Sandra would want to know
that we had a fine Italian American in
charge of the program
um but that Steve does a lot of work on
this and and sort of lives single audit
and Swap and that's sort of his his
whole life and um uh we work very
cooperatively with agencies although as
you might imagine um everybody hates
Auditors from an agency level but they
work very well with them the the an
audit finds things that's very important
you don't want to do an audit that found
nothing because you'd wonder what they
were looking at um but the chart that
Dana started showing you about 5 years
ago is a meant to be a summary uh so you
can say okay I know you found some
things it are we getting better are we
getting worse or we where are we and we
are getting better and the corrective
action plans are very important and and
and I would say that the culture of the
state is such that um agencies really do
take them very seriously and and I would
argue that they take them probably more
seriously now than they did five six
seven eight years ago there's a there's
a lot of most of the corrective actions
they take are actually actions and
actually correct things which in the
past sometimes people used to pay lip
service on occasion anyway we have a
very good relationship and it's a very
good audit and a testament to that is
the snap tanif and Medicaid programs we
had findings in the previous year the
corrective action plans were implemented
and as I previously reported we had no
findings over those three programs so
you can see as Charlie just explained
that
progression Senator GR um I agree that
corrective action plans are very
important and as when I used to be a
manager I used to go make sure that if I
had a repeat item that I went and looked
at my correct corrective action plan and
made sure that I was either on track or
found out what the problem is and I'm
sure you're doing that and I'd just like
to get a comment we do um because the
car of action plan is our our um thing U
Steve does it um and and manages that
program for us um he's a senior manager
in in the division of accounting
services uh and regularly communicates
if you were to ask any agency who gets
one they would argue they none of them
would argue that he's not aggressive
enough um occasionally people think he's
a little too aggressive um we get
quarterly updates we insist that they
come and and if the updates if the
updates don't come the the commissioner
of the agency is required to explain and
occasionally there are managers who get
annoyed by that there's there are a lot
of people get annoyed every time you you
write their boss like somehow if you
told the governor something I was doing
I'd be annoyed with you but um I don't
actually feel that way but the uh uh we
go after it very aggressively and the
Auditors the next year also follow up
very
aggressively thank you further from the
committee let it be on the record that I
hold Auditors in high
regard and I don't think we could do
this job on this committee without them
or do a budget with without them and I
appreciate efforts and their
thoroughness and I believe the rest of
the committee feels the same way
representative thank you Mr chair is it
possible to get a PDF of your
presentation sent to
us um a PD do you have a PDF the report
or just of my speaking of of this or my
speaking notes speaking notes um yes I
can provide that to LBA to send to you
no problem thank you all right anything
further from the committee
members seeing none it has been accepted
placed on file and will be released in
the usual manner uh we're proud to say
that under uh Steve G ganelli and
commissioner and Dana call the
controller that uh we're seeing
improvements because we're obviously
having a lot more money to handle with
roughly the same staff as it was five
years ago
so it's a task um thank you all for your
efforts thank you m young thank
you and the next item I guess would be
to pick the date for the next
meeting correct that third Friday in May
I believe is the um is the 19th 17th May
17th
Senator rosenal thank you I just note
that it's the date of the law
enforcement memorial
so we always
hear oh traffic well music I was
thinking but we've done it we've done it
before I just wanted to point out we'll
be hearing it so that is the same date
and that will
be yeah and some limited uh Park and or
even even access but they make
allowances for us so thank you for
pointing that out we'll be ready for the
music does that work for the LBA it
does is uh 10 o'cl
sufficient on May 17th for the next
fiscal meeting
without objection we'll set that
date thank you all for
coming and uh for getting through all
that all those
items is there a motion to adjourn
motion toj second all in favor say I I
we are adjourned thank you very
much I think you're right well
done for